- Next up, coming in from Luigi,
"Any suggestions on how
to better communicate
"with people from other countries?
"I mean foreign languages,
"different cultures, different beliefs."
So, I mean, Steve is a
great guy to talk to.
He's got offices around the world,
thousands and thousands of employees.
How do you handle it, Stephen?
- Yeah, I think Luigi, I
think the great thing is,
and this is the power of the Internet,
is everything's available.
'Cause I think there's
a love about business,
that you want to become,
always educating yourself
more and more, and you
know, Evan, I speak to you,
great business people are
just great people in life.
Normally they're very
tolerant, they love diversity,
they love inclusion, they've
got tremendous outreach,
and they kind of love the
stranger, in many respects.
And when you're going and you look at
your business, Luigi, whether you're going
kind of across the
border or you're looking
to going out to Asia or
Europe, first of all,
I'd almost say again, back
to kind of Evan said it is,
do a bit of research about
the culture, the difference,
and how your idea might translate.
Then the other thing is, the
great thing about if you live
in Canada or US, you'll
find loads of people,
whether they come from,
could be Asia, Africa.
They're probably within half
a mile of where you are.
Go and test-drive some stuff in terms of
how it might work with them.
The great thing I've
experienced is obviously,
the world is diverse, we
celebrate the tolerance,
and actually everything
is fantastic about,
cities like Toronto, you
walk down the street there,
it's a fantastic multicultural center.
Same with New York, same with London,
but in reality, what I would say,
the nice thing about
products and services,
if you got a great idea, it can go global.
It can go viral, and the
Internet has no respect
for international boundaries,
and that's the game changer
in the last 13 years.
That gives you a huge platform
cuz you now have a
canvas that is the world.
That is your canvas,
that is your playground.
So I definitely think
it's worth going for it,
look into it and do research on the web,
and then, road-test stuff.
Launch a (bad audio) an Italian website.
Before you had to get translated stuff.
You can do (bad audio) translation stuff,
then get an Italian friend
just to cast their eye over it,
make sure it all makes sense.
You can go and have an e-commerce
platform with your product
and test-drive it into that marketplace.
It's just incredible, we've
got loads of customers,
great customer of ours, Jen
O'Price, who started a business
up in the north of England, Yorkshire.
She started a great organic,
really healthy food business,
and now, I think she
exports to 29 countries,
loads of different currencies,
and when she started her journey,
she was passionate about
healthy, organic eating.
That was her dream, and really,
if we're honest with ourself,
she probably didn't know
she'd be as successful as she has been,
and she didn't know she'd
be in as many countries.
But I think what the power is, and again,
it comes back to kind of
believing in yourself,
and everything Evan talks
to, is if you've got
a great product, almost,
if you put it out there,
the market will find it,
it will create a pull,
instead of what was the old way
where you had to push, push, push, push.
So you've got that kind of
canvas around the world,
find out and do the research,
and then I would go for it.
Road-test it, test-drive it,
and scale up on what works.
Evan?
- Yeah, I have two thoughts.
The first thing that comes to mind
is that the intent is most important.
I think a lot of people avoid
going into another market
or dealing with people
from different cultures
because they're just really
worried that they don't
speak the language or they
don't know the culture,
and that prevents them
from taking any action.
Your intent is most important.
If you know that you can
solve this person's problem
in that market, then you
should go out and do it,
because it's coming from a good place.
Yes, you're going to make some mistakes,
you're going to trip up a couple times,
and the thing that gets
you through is the intent.
You're not going in there
trying to harm them,
you're going in there trying to help,
and even if you make a couple mistakes,
you say the wrong word that
maybe, you mispronounce it,
it becomes something offensive,
you can work your way through
it because they can feel
the genuine care that
you have, to try to help.
Don't let that fear of
not knowing the culture
prevent you from doing something
potentially really helpful
and great in that market.
So that's first-
- You've got your second point,
you go for your second point.
No, go on, I'm just in the
mood now, so go for it.
- Okay, the second point was I
think, something that Stephen
does actually really well,
is he's always hyper-aware
of what's happening in
the markets of the places
that he's going to, and
so every time we get on,
he's talking about the Blue Jays,
he's talking about my prime minister,
he's always super aware
of what's happening
in the markets he's going to.
I would like to think that
Stephen's favorite baseball team
of all time is the Toronto Blue Jays.
You're going to break my
heart Stephen, if you say no.
- Yes, go Jays.
- But he's really great at
that, and so if you know
you're going to a local
market, just understanding
some things about them,
understanding what's relevant
in the news, understanding,
I like baseball
but I don't pay attention to other things.
It allows you to have some
points of commonality,
and doing a little bit more
research and groundwork
before going in can really help,
just a couple of touchpoints really helps,
makes a difference when you're
communicating with them.
- When you're talking there,
and I was just listening,
and again, you've got
a great gift of putting
the human touch on things,
just a little thing I do
when I go around the world,
I'm in Berlin next week, I'm presenting,
I don't know, couple of thousand people,
but my first three
sentences will be in German.
If you're going to be, or
you get on Skype with people
in I don't know, Italy, down in Brazil,
and you're looking to strike
some sort of partnership
or distribution agreement with them,
it's pretty powerful, especially
actually face-to-face.
If you learn a couple of opening,
you just say bonjour, je
m'appelle Stephen Kelly.
I go to Canada, up to Montreal,
if I can speak a little bit in French ...
That means you break the ice,
cuz I think what we forget,
and it's so easy to forget,
because it's kind of voices
in our head tell us people are strangers,
but the reality is, when you
show a bit of vulnerability
like that and say, look, I
don't speak very good French
but at least I had a go
because I respect you,
and I respect your nation and culture.
Then I've always found people reach out
and actually embrace you,
and it's very powerful.
It's just a very human thing to say,
but it's something where you can go to,
and if you looking to go overseas,
then as you say, do a bit of
research about what's topical,
what's happening in the news,
what's happening with Justin Trudeau
and all that sort of stuff
when we go to Canada,
if the Blue Jays are winning.
But then also, if you can, say a few words
in their language, it's so powerful.
I remember when I used to go to Tokyo,
I had a business out there, and literally
first couple of sentences of saying kanji,
and then that exhausted my
totality of my Japanese,
but honestly, you hear
stuff about the Japanese.
They're very civilized and
they're very respectful
and they're lovely people,
but you hear it's really hard
to go to Japan, it's a
difficult market to break into,
but I think if you show
a bit of interest in them
and their culture, and if you
can even say two sentences,
then you find them grabbing
you and bringing you
into their community and making
a success in their world.